ces images que vous voyez actuellement
la vessie ce qui restait du viaduc de la
concorde à laval après son effondrement
6 à 8 ans il ya cinq personnes qui
avaient perdu la vie mais vous savez
malgré les blâmes de la commission
denquête malgré toutes les victimes
aussi
radio canada a appris qu'aucune plein
aucun blanc ne sera déposée par l'ordre
des ingénieurs sauf pour un cas mineurs
lors donc ferme
onze des douze dossiers d'enquêté sur
cette tragédie josé thibault
l'effondrement du viaduc de la concorde
a fait cinq morts six blessés et donné
lieu à la commission denquête johnson
parmi les conclusions des manquements
bien identifiés dans les agissements de
certains ingénieurs liés à la conception
et plus tard à la réflexion de l'
ouvrage reproche à l'ingénieur sanogo sa
gestion des travaux de 92 qui était pas
question de faire des en-cas et des
puits de regarder la situation
d'aujourd'hui en termes de construction
tpi puis base et des dépôts de plaintes
en fonction des noms d'aujourd'hui il
fallait se replacer dans le temple c'est
ce qui était très complexe
quarante ans après la construction du
viaduc il a donc été impossible de
prouver la responsabilité d'une ou des
personnes et de les blâmer document
introuvable ingénieur décédées sont
parmi les raisons évoquées
le syndic dit que l'ordre a appris de la
complexité de ce dossier et qu'il a
maintenant ajuster son tir
ainsi dans le dossier du paralumes
tomber dans le tunnel viger il y a trois
ans les enquêtes sont complétés et des
plaintes seront portés cet automne
contre des ingénieurs du consortium
responsable mais l'ordre des ingénieurs
ville contrecoup des dénonciations
actuelle dans le milieu de la
construction et croule sous les demandes
dans quai les dossiers en 2009 étaient
des dossiers caractère technique
comment faisait 60 80 par année en ce
moment le syndic doit enquêter sur six
fois plus de cas qu'en 2009
définitivement il avait les mains liées
piètre excuse selon un ex vice président
de l'ordre qui croient que le syndic
s'est traîné les pieds et qu'il manque
de moyens je comprends qu'ils aient eu
des problèmes perso chose ce qui pouvait
s'y attendre peut-être il aurait dû
arrêter ça bien avant
josé s cas des membres des commissions
gens sont justement qui ont réagi
écouter personne n'a retourné nos appels
et s'arrêter très intéressant parce que
vous l'avez entendu non seulement
pierre-marc johnson a nommé des
ingénieurs mais il a également décrit
les manquements qu'il avait constaté par
exemple surveillance inadéquate
vérification de travaux qui n'étaient
pas fait correctement et contrôle de
qualité inexistant et on aurait aimé
savoir ce qu'il pensait des conclusions
de l'ordre des ingénieurs et du côté des
victimes même chose il ya beaucoup de
discrétion de ce côté là et tout ce
qu'on nous a dit c'est écoutez on en est
maintenant passer à autre chose ce qu'on
espère maintenant à l'ordre des
ingénieurs c'est que le fait qu'on va
pas commencer à pouvoir déposer des
accusations dans d'autres dossiers dont
le tunnel viger
mais ça ça va peut-être commencer à
rebâtir la confiance du public envers
les ingénieurs merci beaucoup josé
revoir